let's talk about a real victim Rob can
you pull up this victim deer in Aspen
video that I sent you set can we set
this up yeah go ahead and set it up very
and then you take it so so we're in
Aspen the the house that that this guy
and dude one of the best Christmases
I've had and I love you for for inviting
me this house is like the the Dumb and
Dumber it's like the sickest house bro
it's snowing it's skiing it's everything
we're already going to go ski all right
we're we're in route Mario um is going
with Ethan and they're leaving Ethan his
son looks back and goes hey Dad I think
cuz there's two there's a pool there's
everything there's a there's a lake it's
kind of iced over and he goes I think a
deer just fell in the lake and Mar's
already leaving he's like what he's like
are you kidding he goes no I'm telling
you a deer
Mario turns around gets out uh the chef
uh Alper he comes out and he's recording
this and just to throw this out there
Mario is an aspen he's a Guatemalan dude
okay and out of nowhere he yells at
Ethan he's like but go go get a rope and
then P I'll let you I'll let you take
the story he gets the rope and then
played from here go ahead Rob just play
from right here there's a a deer Fell in
This an aspin go ahead watch this okay
that's Mario walking by the way that
Lake he steps on that he's going down
he's going that's the deer listen one
last so throw one last so that's that's
Mario screaming no no that's scre watch
this come on he got it with one throw
atam last need help that's Al how the
hell did Mario he's on the ledge he's on
the edge of the ice that's the most
dangerous part good job
dude well now we know how your
sound look at this
dude oh it's amazing Mario
Bro the City of Aspen needs to send a
letter to Mario agular watch this the
deer is about to die can't get up he's
trying to stand up on the ice at him and
his hes keep so watch what Mario does as
if he's done this 50 times I'm watching
this video I'm thinking of local support
you know guys coming from the city and
then I look at the camera I'm like
that's
Mario dude look at this a
guow like rest of it and you can tell
the dear trust him at this point they
have a relationship have a
relationship dude watch this bro watch
this slow down you're good let me get
he runs into fence yeah deer shoots him
3 minutes after by the way so so that's
the day the hero I know this
sounds I know this sounds like a what
I'm telling you right now like it's
straight out of a movie so that's Mario
the next morning I get up no joke to
walk outside and my dad's like go see
what's outside Rob I just sent you the
Tweet pull up the tweet I just
sent that's the one watch that one turn
the audio on look at this look at this
dude look at this this is the next day
oh I saw this video yeah they're all
here look at these guys surrounded by
Elks almost looks like a they came to
pay respect to their Godfather Mario
from the
movie Leave the World
Behind but it also looks like every
Hunter's dream oh look at all that meat
is that James Earl Jones Voice or is
that you CLE by the way there's 200 of
them outside easily they gave a prayer
they saluted at Mario they made a
certain unique chance and they're just
saying we just want to thank on behalf
of the elk and a deer Community thank
you Mario I don't I don't think people I
don't think people realize Mario has
never taken a rope and lasto in his life
he threw it in one shot if he doesn't
get it in that one shot that deer is
dead I don't even know if Mario's ever
even been around a deer no dude and then
mind you he's on the edge of the water
which is the most D and then he's like
Ethan come over here come add to this
danger by the way if they go in it's a
WAP they don't know how to get out of
that let me tell you something all right
I'm not I'm not gonna say any you know
Mario just became a father Yes okay uh
young Gabriel's how old is Gabriel now
maybe like six months less than six
months less than six months I don't know
when a man and woman after giving a
child when you go again but when Mario's
wife Barbie sees that video I'm just
saying there might be another baby in 9
months it's already done I'm just
saying you know what lines you can
officially use on your girl I love it
when you save Deer I save Bambi baby
what do you mean what do you mean Bambi
and Barbie what do you mean when she
sees the video she's pregnant
again don't stop rumors I'm joking
anyways hey all right it's good to be
back Mario you're amazing ASP Aspen if
you're listening send this man a letter
thanking him for what he did to the deer
in Aspen so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right
here